we're introducing this idea of mechanics
as a whole topic right
and we said the big difference between
extension one
motion and extension two motion wise
what's the big difference
mass very good so when you take these
two key ideas
which we have done to death into an
extension one right
and when you add mass to them velocity
and mass together we gave it the name
momentum that's right
okay and its unit was kilogram meters
per second
yes because it's a velocity meters per
second
plus mass kilogram meters per second
okay and then we say well if you do the
same thing with acceleration
you bring mass into the equation what do
we call it
force thank you
so you've got acceleration and mass
considered together that's a force
right now just like this was kilogram
meters per second
this was kilograms per meters
sorry kilogram meters per second squared
but we
decided that was such a mouthful right
we invented a whole new
unit for it right now
it's more than just new fancy names and
new units right
they're actually you know it's not just
i'm figuratively and conceptually
bringing mass in
i'm literally taking velocity and
multiplying it
by mass that's why it's kilograms per
second and i'm literally
taking acceleration and multiplying it
by mass
okay so we looked at a quicker example
let's look at another one here
okay so typical setup here is
the mass of an object two kilos here's
an expression for the
force that's acting on that object
in relation to its displacement okay so
we looked at this under extension one
motion before this is no big deal this
this makes sense
we know that sometimes depending on
where something is
different forces are acting on it okay
so so far so good
but now i'm going to pose a different
slightly different question to you right
how am i going to find
velocity as a function of displacement
instead of uh
force as a function of displacement
that's what this is right
so i can see i've got a force
equation here right i've got a mass and
i want a velocity
right so i'm going to begin with this we
start with this
line right f equals m
a and now we can start to fill in right
okay what have i got i've got six minus
four x over here right and then i've got
a so rewriting
okay so suggestions at this point
what should you do remember we've got
all these millions of ways of writing
acceleration and we choose the way
that directs us best toward what we're
trying to get
right so i'm trying to go from a
to v so suggestions
how would you choose
d which way which way you could go
v dv on dx now i believe
did we do this last time did we do this
way last time yeah we did
there's another way right there's
another way to do this and you will see
shortly it's actually a better way what
was the other alternative
it's very similar to this one it's dx of
half v squared right you can see the
clear relationship here
so just to shake it up a little bit
let's go with this let's see what
happens
what was your immediate next line what
did you do
you integrated no problems okay we can
integrate
half b squared equals
3x minus
x squared okay so far so good now what
plus a constant okay now what
so you wanted to you want to evaluate
the constant g is that what you want to
do
yes so you take these
i'll just get another color so i don't
mix this up with everything else
you say when x equal to one v is equal
to two so what will you get on the left
hand side
a half times two squared which is
two here you'll get
three minus one plus c yes
so what's c equal to okay so if you
forgot to put on the cost of integration
lucky u doesn't matter in this case okay
so so far we have this
now what
yeah so now what
v equals plus or minus
so now what
seriously don't have to be afraid
because
everyone else in the room has said the
same thing just say it again
they must be positive now why do you say
like all 15 of you that i've already
checked why do you say we must be
positive
you look at this condition that's what
you've done right
we've looked at this condition now that
is not a bad way to go
it's not a bad way to go um in most
circumstances
it'd be fine and you'd say therefore
positive case only
ah but there's something you're missing
something you're missing
now before i tell you what's missing let
me just remind you right
what makes trials and by extension you
know the actual hsc
difficult is that rather than the tests
you've been having so far which is like
oh i know it's these topics
so i know what i'm looking for and then
i know it's these topics so know what
i'm looking for right
final hsc they're just like here's a
question it could be
anything right so you have to rack your
brains to think through what do i know
that i'm gonna need to bring to bear on
this question right
so you're all in mechanics mode right
you're like okay this is all good so far
but there's something that you know in
here
that will help you answer this question
and in fact not
say that because it's not true
it is both that's right this is the
final answer but the question is why
now admittedly right oh it's a force i
used to think about that but
a force is primarily that acceleration
right so if i rewrote it in a form that
you're more familiar with
x double dot
equals that right it's still maybe not
quite perfectly obvious to you what do i
need to change
to make it super obvious say it again
well uh yeah okay i'm just gonna think
about i'm not gonna worry about units
right now so the number will be there
but what's the condition that actually
makes that makes this thing special
right well it's in this form isn't it
how do i do this i suppose i should put
a minus
four out the front and that would make
this let's see
it'll make an x minus oh what three on
two
three and two what's that
that's minus n squared x minus x naught
this is simple harmonic motion
right so in simple harmonic motion of
course you can go both ways
depending on which side of the center of
um um motion that you are right
namely nearly there i guess
so so it's done uh we forget to look for
those kinds of things because there was
no big flashing sign saying
simple harmonic motion right but that's
why we labeled this point and said ah
there's ways to know
that it's simple harmonic motion other
than this
right you you push the center of um
motion somewhere else and you'll get
this kind of situation
okay now before we finish uh some of you
were suggesting before
that instead of using this we should use
this
okay now yesterday i introduced to you a
different way of doing this
of not having to evaluate a constant
not having an indefinite integral down
there how did we do it what was the
alternative
how would you rework this
so we're going to integrate both sides
with respect to different things
yes so i'm going to have v dv over here
3 minus 2
x dx over here okay now when you slap
the integrals on this
because this is with respect to v i want
v boundaries right now i've got one
i've got one namely this guy right
so i should have a two there okay over
here
on the next boundary and i also have one
right actually it's
it's one now hold on a second
now i've got two spots i've got two
spots what do i put in there
the answer is well i don't know what
they are that's kind of the point
i want v as a function of x right so my
dummy variable is in fact going to be
the variable right so let's go ahead
let's do it right
integrate what do i get
half b squared no surprises there okay
um between two and v okay what do i get
over here
this is what i had before right
from one to x no constants of
integration inside
right what happens
half v squared minus
x minus x squared minus
minus three minus one which is which is
three minus one right yeah
which is which is minus two okay so this
constant and this constant are going to
disappear of course they should they
should you knew they would right
so a half v squared equals three x minus
x squared just like you got before it's
the same thing
right you're gonna dot dot dot you're
gonna get to here
okay so you've got well it's roughly the
same amount of working but i quite like
this way of
ignoring the fact that you don't need to
worry about a constant integration